Freiburg die Grüne vorzeige-
Metropole der Republik
hier regiert der erste Grüne
Bürgermeister einer deutschen
Großstadt
die Region sieht sich als
Vorreiter der ökologischen
Wende
Bio und öko sind in
Atomkraft
mitten in der Stadt Mahnwachen
gegen Atomkraft
kein Wunder dass auch hier eine
der größten Firmen für
Solartechnik steht
die solar-fabrik in Freiburg
stellt Module für
photovoltaik-anlagen hier
800000 pro Jahr
produziert für Frankreich
Italien und Eigenheimbesitzer in
Deutschland
die Schwarzwälder sind stolz
darauf
Pioniere in Sachen Umweltschutz
zu sein
es hat sehr lange Tradition aus
der Forschung heraus aus der
Entwicklung heraus und
natürlich aus der Einstellung
zur Natur
im letzten Jahr hatten es die
Solarfirmen schwer
die Laufzeitverlängerung der
Atomkraftwerke hat die Branche
in eine Krise gestürzt
durch die Ereignisse in Japan
erwartet der Chef eine
politische Wende
Weg vom Atomstrom
in zu Alternativen Energien
obwohl natürlich schon wenn
jetzt sich die
Laufzeitverlängerung Deuterium
das dann Prozent
Andorf nehme und wenn Investoren
wie zum Beispiel werden
Gemeinden die eigene Versorgung
in der Energieversorgung in
aufgebaut haben und von ihnen
eigene Energie versorgen
Solarparks investiert haben
dass das Geschäft was im ersten
Quartal Gewinne tief
Prozent sowohl gekommen ist dass
das sich wieder belebt
Schönau im Schwarzwald
kaum 40 Kilometer von Freiburg
entfernt
hier ist selbst die Kirche schon
mit einem Solardach bestückt
die Bürger haben Ende der
Neunzigerjahre außerdem ihre
Elektrizitätswerke selbst
übernommen
die mit vielen ihren Strom
hauptsächlich aus
Wasserkraftwerken in Norwegen
von Schönau ausverkauften die
Bundesbank
AFP
bis zu 300 Neukunden haben sie
seit der Katastrophe in Japan am
Tag das hatten sie früher in
der Woche
mit angebaut
aber dass sie die gleiche
Qualität und Wünsche und
Wilhelm Busch durch die
Dichtungen über Oudin Michael
Sladek führt das Unternehmen er
meint
wählt man als Kunde einen der
großen Energieversorger weiß
man nicht ob der Strom aus
Atomkraftwerken kommen voran
wenn sie in Strom hat pro
Mut machen wollen einen
richtigen Wechsel nahmen dann
müssen sie nicht nur schon
wieder der Strom produziert
sondern Profis ihr Geld geben
nur so können sie eine
Veränderung in der Wirtschaft
heuer erreichen indem sie
einfach kein Geld höchst
gleichzeitig können
nach Frankfurt
das fraunhofer-institut
hier sind sie auf Solartechnik
spezialisiert
sie forschen daran wie
Deutschland auf Alternative
Energien umstellen kann
hier treffen sie Anlagen für
Solarhersteller
sie alle sind davon überzeugt
dass die ökowende und der
komplette Umstieg auf
Alternative Energien
zu schaffen ist
das hängt mit Sinne von
Hauptmieter staunt man sich auch
Rückblicke und engagiert waren
ambitioniert man das Thema
vorantreibt
es gibt Studien die wir mit
Prozent den Annahmen oder
Forschungsinstituten Ommerborn
in dem Bereich gemacht haben
dass es auf jeden Fall bis 2050
schaffen
am mehr Intensität 3 9
da ist sicherlich denkbar dass
man auch bis 2030 umsteigen kann
viele Freiburger setzen auf
Solarkraft
auch wenn wir nicht immer die
Sonne scheint
SID München sich dass die ihre
energiesparenden Ideen
für ganz Deutschland werden
könnten